and we are back here as promised we are
bringing you perhaps the last and maybe
maybe only interview that would remain
as far as needing needing to complete
what has been quite the journey here not
not an exciting one but a rather unique
and disappointing one but here with us
super Grand Master tamer Roger Bobb came
over first of all thank you so much for
joining us the fans cannot wait to hear
from you
yeah thank you very much for reminding
me thanks so I'll start off it and just
say that we've we've obviously been kind
of going around the horn today talking
to a lot of different people getting a
lot of different opinions but you stated
and and sort of saw the coming curve
here earlier than anybody you you you
know acted with integrity and expressed
your viewpoint that you felt it should
be postponed and the only way that you
could really have any power or make your
voice heard was to was to be a you know
act on your principles in withdraw you
did so the tournament has been postponed
how are you dealing with all of this how
are you feeling and is there some
vindication you're feeling and what in
the world would possibly make this right
to you
well first of all of course I have
expressed myself in the letter that I
have sent you kobish at first and then
as you know talking about although I
mean the legal actions that feeder can
take in that situation he told me that I
mean if he sent in a letter official
letter back and it was written that it
cannot be postponed non legally known
practically which the letter was in
Russian so please correct me if I'm
translating it right but it was written
like this so that it cannot be postponed
non legally known practically also I was
told by the high profile feed
representatives that including the
president affiliate that the point is
that they are following cold instruction
of the authorities of Russia and so on
and they do not stop the tournaments so
everything is fine and things like this
but actually later on the minister of
sports of Russia said I impress and it's
available the materials are aligned we I
can actually later send to you or you
can find it yourself he says that he
says that in one of his interviews that
the International Federations if they
want to postpone events at the territory
of Russia they should send this kind of
you know the message or the you know the
request to the Ministry of sports and
then they can take this decision I was
told otherwise that once they are not
stopping the events that the Russian
Ministry of sports feel they cannot take
any actions okay this was the first
thing that they said which contradicts
with the words of the minister of sports
which I guess is that right authority
you know to - you know how things are in
Russians afterwards you know after
sending this letter and receiving this
reply and then I've got this deadline
actually I've posted it on my Instagram
account and there were these letters of
feeder with the you know with the
deadline and so on that I mean I could
say yes I could say no I could say
whatever
actually but in case beside yes I mean
the yes I'm playing in this
circumstances I could only I mean there
were two options either say okay no take
me out of the tournament because I
disagree with this and the second one
was not to answer which would be
considered the same more or less just a
few hours before the deadline I said
okay if this is possible to move the
event okay okay but beside that they at
the time somehow so that you know the
situation is not any kind of critical
and so on they were referring to some
tournaments that is still going on going
there but the difference between the fee
day event and the ongoing tournaments is
that they're ongoing that is the point
and once you are considering to start
the event in this circumstances you
first of all have to take some kind of
you know I don't know if it's analysis
or the general assembly or feeder or
what is it called like I mean or there
are a few people who have to you have to
you know talk to each other and decide
what what should be done in this
situation I don't know how it works so
generally I think decision decision
there they had to take the right
decision in my opinion now it proves to
be proved to be right and they're taking
it's creating the whole entire mess you
know especially in you know in this
contenders that are playing there now
with you know plus plus course and so on
so now the situation is super
complicated in general I think feeder
should take some action to include me
back into the tournament that's what I
saying and I think it's a fair decision
or I mean from my side I think I have
done everything there possible and I
just asked them burn them actually I
also weren't you know the chess
community by expressing it openly and so
on but there was no action by feeder and
now we're in this situation beside that
on the 16th of March there was the press
statement I mean the statement from the
Ministry of sports of Russia that all
the sport events should be stopped
should be stopped on the you know on the
Russian territory for for you know
before they send a new letter or
something or they confirm the new you
know dates that are possible
whatever events and so on and then feed
them
I was already I think conducting this
ridiculous opening ceremony with a few
thousand people and actually there at
this ceremony they've got the message
and they certainly had to stop the UN
but then there was some kind of I think
some kind of risk not the press release
icing some interview or something of nor
Kovich and sue Tosca and they said that
we are not being shut down because we
have started on 15th of March I mean I
don't know even should I really comment
on this I mean is it something you know
well it's I should also consult the
lawyers see how it's going you know and
also all this you know replies and all
this stuff that you know if you
dimensioned in their letter and so on
and I'm really disappointed with the
situation I mean it's like you know that
this will happen this happens in the
middle of the tournament the most
important tournament in chess the entire
world is laughing con us because we're
the only ones who started the UN at this
time I guess especially the the you know
they went of this caliber you know I
mean we only have like one most
important event in chess was saying in
the individual chess is like the World
Championship match and as you have seen
I mean all the chess players during the
entire tournament they were expressing
you know their you know their vision on
how it's going and going to do it at all
and the hostile hostile circumstance is
therefore be shook and how and all the
others and actually in my letter I
expressed that the I mean I've sent a
letter in Russian I think it was it was
translated from different sides and I
think there I mean I just said that
besides all the situation with the
coronavirus and that the tournament is
not clear what we will do and actually
it's it was not clear for anyone they
said they know what they are doing they
took all the measures and stuff and as
we know that
okay fides is the authority in chess but
as you can see this even a huge states
with with a great power and you know the
abilities and so on they cannot
the virus but feed is somehow said that
they're able to really do everything
possible there in the situation but
actually nothing is nothing you can do
about it to be honest at the moment that
it's not clear what you really should do
there beside the postponing the event in
this circumstances and as you can see
for example the billion dollars
industries are suffering from this and
they're moving events that cost later
hundreds of millions of euros and
dollars and so on and actually we cannot
postpone one of the most important may
be yeah one of the most important
tournaments in chess just for the you
know I know for five six months is let's
say with the possibility to play it at
the end of the year and so on which
would be a just a normal thing to do you
know I mean all the other events as well
are getting postponed now in chess and
all canceled and so on some and a lot of
them were canceled I said before before
the candidates as well so I I just can't
understand it I mean it's like I just
can't understand it to those yeah well
Taymor you've given us a lot to work
with here and I have a you know question
for you so we had some officials from
feed a on earlier and part of what they
were saying was one the situation in
Russia was not so bad at the time at two
they felt that you gave sort of an
ultimatum and so I just want to ask you
first what information were you looking
at that led you to your decision because
I am strongly in agreement with you and
also can you tell everybody what it
means to you to play in the candidates
and potentially have a chance at the
World Championship because I have to
assume you did not make this decision
lightly sorry for the second one so for
the first time there stood yeah and the
second so you know what would have
playing in the cannon cement to you or a
chance playing the World Championship
because I assume you do not make this
decision lightly
uh yeah I don't get second he's just
trying to give you an opportunity to
share your feelings on how important the
candidates was how upset you are that
you didn't get to play yeah yeah
so first of all I think it was in the
4th of March that I was talking to
DeMarco which at the time and they they
also you know how they actually you know
said that I'm I'm leaving the tournament
for the personal reasons and stuff like
that okay if you if coronavirus and the
whole situation is his personal reasons
what can I say but certainly it
certainly it's a strange thing by
feeling that they're they have done
their but okay and regarding the
situation I mean I was receiving I mean
I have as all of you and all the other
people that are reading news and all
that stuff but beside that I had some
some conversations with my friends and
people that know some stuff in general
in different circles here and in Russia
and actually when the worker which told
me that according to his information
it's not yet that bad and so on and
probably it's going to be okay I said
that according to my information is
going to be really bad and I cannot
really build the sources but like
certainly I think that the other people
that were talking to me they probably
don't want to say that they're there you
know I mean they had this information
stuff but actually I was just discussing
it analyzing it myself as well and you
know sometimes I can foresee such things
like you know before in surprise or
stuff like that decide and this is this
is much easier for me to calculate
because it's actually you know connected
with my profession so in general I was
saying all this you know the football
news and all that stuff that probably a
lot of tournaments will be postponed and
already at the time when I was talking
to the coach some of them for sure
respond I actually mentioned that the
sport events are getting canceled around
the world in my letter so generally it
was also I mean even with the you know
just
general information was enough to
understand that you will not run this
kind of event of this importance that is
very easy to postpone
I mean it's compared to European you
know European soccer Cup and you know
all these huge events and especially now
we can see the Olympics and so on I mean
it was so easy to foresee it I don't
really see a problem I don't understand
why others who were I mean elegant of
this because maybe sometimes people are
just I mean until it will reach their
region or reach their country they don't
see this as a coming threat you know and
we were like always ok with it ok there
is a fluid it's just normal to feel
sometimes not to speak or something like
this and the probably is just going to
you know the fade at some point and I
fade away whatever and be fine for
everyone but in fact with my analysis I
clearly saw that it's going to be hard
to play this three weeks completely out
of any concentration in this case trying
to just keep yourself you know working
as Magnus says as you're already at the
job you have to do it there yes
certainly there you would be you know
sleeping going to the game preparing and
stuff like that will be trying to
concentrate on your games but it's very
hard I mean it's in this circumstance
this is really hard well now we can see
that I mean they're even having problems
to move back home you know to come back
and you know their home countries and so
on at the time of course I didn't know
that this will happen but surfing there
so that conducting such you went for you
know three weeks will be unbearable and
I mean certainly hard for me of
psychological to play in the
circumstances I was receiving the
informations like every second you know
almost like from entire world that
everything is shutting down and stuff
like that and all the soccer events are
getting canceled if you cancel such a
big events you understand that measures
are taken because everybody understand
it is huge it's not it's not something
simple and on that second question I
mean tell us a little bit about how hard
you've been preparing for the candidates
that as Robert said how much it would
have meant to you to be able to play and
have a chance at the World Chess
Championship well it's always hard to
you know to judge about the chances I
mean it's always it's always problematic
because for example certainly I was not
considered yeah I was not considered the
player who is going to win
world cup let's say I was not the clear
favorite or something and was not a
favorite even I guess but at the same
time everyone has chances especially you
know in this tournaments of high level
depends how you how you approach it
certainly I mean I was playing at the
top level and still playing at the top
level for a long time so certainly I
know some stuff about just so how to
prepare and so on but you never know
until you start the tournament how it's
going you know for sure for sure for
example you wouldn't expect that I mean
the ignorant to start like this or or
probably even karana to be at this core
at this in this after the six or seven
rounds or whatever and yeah I was
preparing with the ability attrition of
karyakin and linear dominguez and
actually with with karyakin and Shatila
we have spent like months I think of the
training sessions and we were preparing
for the tournament actually did a lot of
stuff but as I said you never know I
mean it's you can be super prepared and
then play bat or you can be unprepared
and play amazingly sometimes but the
point is you were preparing that's the
point right
revealing your team of seconds so go
ahead keep going
no go ahead seconds is not it's not a
world championship match the time
revealing before that and beforehand and
I can even say that I would still play
the openings that I like to play so it's
not a problem for me to be honest I I
don't really you know it's like it's
like for some other players as well but
I mean it's you know it's not the kind
of super preparation that I was hiding
or stuff like that I I just don't like
to be you know to express the
preparation when it's ongoing before I
mean like give it does for example his
Instagram or something I mean it's fine
I mean some players I think they're I
mean Magnus I don't see a lot of force
of him what he's doing I'd say recently
for gear is different karana
even sometimes that there is a leak of
his preparation and stuff like that but
in my case you know some stinkonium
think
or general and to Iraq and chuchi loaf
and Mingus I mean actually yeah they're
mostly mostly I'm working with Chu Chu
law sometimes practicing with Sergey and
this is this is the way I'm preparing
but also of course working on my own but
in this case of course we were preparing
we were sure that the tournament is
going to happen and in advance when we
started the preparation but then it was
more clear and clear I mean at least
getting to to me I mean Sergey and Bazzi
Amir I think he's always he's always in
Belgium generally no - and I don't think
that much can happen there a guy
hopefully everything will be fine
because he's living in a very very small
town I guess I hope that it will not get
there to him so in this case I mean we
discover on the virus I think it was
only me and Sergey or less trying to
understand what's going on and at some
point to meet it became clear that
something will be happening in the
entire world so Timur it sounds like for
those people who are saying oh if raja
baath really wanted to plan the
candidates he would have played it
sounds like you were preparing very hard
and you clearly wanted to plan the
candidates and you wanted that chance or
to play for the world championship
course of course there's no reasons for
me actually to be out of this tournament
or just doing nothing and sitting at
home and actually it's my profession and
besides some jokes that they were
talking about the tight date on the
candidates tournament I was doing them
because there is a kind of tradition in
Azerbaijan is when you say that how to
say that you don't want let's say for
example kind of saying I know exactly
how to translate it to English but it's
like when you say that you're you're not
trying to win and you are trying to
bring luck this way so that what I was
doing through the entire interviews of
the World Cup and actually and the final
interview I said guys it was of course
all the jokes and so on of course I was
trying to win and every game that I'm
playing certainly visible by the style
of the games I've played that was all
the fighting games in the world happened
so so this I mean there are always
things that people are talking when they
don't understand jokes and humor so it's
just fine for me I'm just fine
of course I was happy to play I mean
it's I know you never know if it's your
last candidates tournament or things
like this because getting there is
really hard this it's a huge thing I
mean especially that I was really almost
dead after this tournament in the
hunting season
after spending one month and then at
some point when actually I won a game
against ding clearin and I had still to
play the you know the the rabbit against
one of the top players that recently
beat feresten like 2-0 in the san luis
you know the tie breaks and stuff I was
like almost that there and it's like you
get this you know you get the sports to
the candidates you get this money for
playing on the highest level and things
like this only by a huge concentration
of all your you know the the physical
condition I don't know the chess
abilities and stuff it's so hard and of
course I wouldn't just simply decline to
play in such a tournament for no reason
and it helps I think remind everybody I
think just of course we know that you're
the number 9 you know player in the
world and and and we certainly know how
you feel about that it's giving giving a
voice to you know a lot of people on the
outside looking in they speculate they
say things but it's very clear but
you've you've you know had a dream of
becoming world champion I think it's all
just professionals do right since you
were very young
yeah otherwise you just leave more or
less the game I can say right in the
interviews that I'm not going to be I
mean I'm not trying to win the world
championship but in my mind and my
emotional state is that the if I'm
playing chess in general that my only
hope is to become the world champion who
chances I have or small chances or I'm a
favorite or no favorite or stuff like
that
otherwise that would be just not playing
chess right well I want to come back
sorry right well no joy Danny I wanted
to come back to to what you said about
what in your mind would make this right
and not not to take any position of
playing devil's advocate at all but
obviously we've been talking to a lot of
different people right and and this
event is going for a weekend and so just
to give you the floor right it's a very
difficult situation I'm sure that they
as they view it from their position but
from your position it makes a little
sense that may be the only way to make
this right would be to let you back in
there has been talk
if fidei suggested that you would be
given a wild card or a guaranteed spot
to the next candidates is that something
you would accept or is it pretty much at
this point you feel that the only
justice to be served would be a
reshaping and reforming of this year's
2020 candidates at this point I mean
it's to be honest hard to discuss what
would be the clearly right decision
except of letting me play in the
tournament and certainly started again
because this situation is extremely
strange especially I'm not sure I want
to hear from all the other players as
well I mean the carillon and all the
others the Chinese that were you know as
one house if he was pressed to play
there but this I don't know I mean it's
up to him he has to speak out for
himself in this case but well I mean I
don't hear anything from Fira that comes
out at least in the news interviews and
so on that makes me understand for now
that they're going to take any proper
action in my opinion which would be to
include me in tournament started again
probably I guess now the situation is
that you have to play with nine players
understand it but I don't see any other
way of doing it for now but beside that
they are not even discussing this at the
moment they're not even telling the bear
or some kind of discussions ongoing so
probably their idea for now is to try to
see what's going on in Russia with the
virus situation and so on and when they
get can resume you know the I mean all
this the job so I'm going and stuff like
that and then try to play it till the
end as soon as they can and that's all I
can hear I don't know I mean I didn't
really see yet the interview with
Markovich it was earlier today there was
there was no I could I could share with
you there was no discussion specifically
pertaining to to this in regards to
restart a lot of the questions we had
were more pointed at the decision they
made to run the event the Cova 19 of
outbreak how they were handling things
on site those sort of things that I'm
just giving you insight that's all of
course you can check out
but I don't I don't really I mean I will
have to sing also we'll have to see
legally I mean what can be done in the
situation in jail but I'm I'm actually a
lawyer myself but certainly here it is
like some real professionals that are
always there doing their jobs because
I'm certainly a professional chess
player more than a lawyer right so in
this case certainly I see a lot of
problems with the legal interpretation
of what Peter did here but I want first
to consult and see if it's if it's right
from the legal standpoint the
professional lawyers and in this case
also I don't hear anything from field so
that's that's the problem what to hear
maybe they have discussed something now
maybe they will say something but at the
time you know it seems that since it
seems that it's you know it's a it's
still ongoing I mean all the sync with
the first that they didn't take the
right decision now there is no even the
apology or anything at all like it's
just normal and not be apology only to
me but to entire chess community because
what I mean what is going on now it's
it's really shame for purchase because
for example now when when you know that
the situation is approaching especially
closer to fourteens even if my message
was something like really far from from
the reality is what they sold or
something like this but 14 13 12 15 16
so when the Ministry of sports prohibits
all the events on the Russian Chess
Federation and the tournament is not yet
started at all so 15 said the closing at
the opening ceremony they already had
this decision by the Ministry of sports
was it so hard there to first see that
things are going to end like this is it
is it something I mean should you really
know something special about it when
your Ministry of sports I mean the
minister of sports of the country is
hosting this event just says that guys
there is no more sporting events and we
say guys no legally from 15 so we're
starting this tournament seriously is it
is it their real action that the
Federation is responsible for the health
of the chess players or the candidates
for the world crown and all these guys
that are now suffering from this
situation they shouldn't take any
measures in the
case maybe I just don't understand
something so I don't really know well
take more let me ask you a question just
for the sake of clarity you said you
haven't heard from feed a so I want to
ask you a multiple questions here one we
heard four in our interviews today that
they said essentially it's something you
were issuing an ultimatum
so do you agree with that assessment of
your letters to feed a and also when was
the last time Pete I spoke to you about
anything related to the candidates
tournament
um okay so first of all ultimate them
okay so in this case there are also some
speculations and stuff that maybe I had
to talk to the players and stuff but I
mean about the situation and that let's
let's take some you know decision with
all I mean with all the other players or
some other players and stuff but in this
case I guess that it was kind of
sabotaging the tournament this in a way
because I'm just asking other players to
decline their participation in order to
determine not to be offset so would it
be like a sabotaging of the of the event
or not or is there a governing body that
takes the decision to postpone the event
so I saw that it's right to speak
directly to the governing body of you
know the representative of the
Federation so at the time I wrote a
letter to our coach there was a bull
teammate them and you call it an
ultimatum when you say for example that
the situation in the world is like this
I have all the letters you have all the
letters and stuff and in case the
postponement is not possible I will have
to I will have to withdraw from the
tournament I mean what kind of ultimatum
is this I don't have any dates there is
not a deadline I was always there for
discussion was always possible to talk
to me and first letter that I did to
Dwarka which was not even an open letter
so he could really express things and
talk with me and discuss the situation
what he actually did is that he said
that he talked to me and said that we
will have two days to discuss the
situation then this came the ultimatum
from Feder that came to me because it
was it was a deadline with clear time
when I have to support my decision with
the official withdrawal withdrawal from
the tournament so this was their
ultimatum comes from feeded from from my
understanding yeah and we heard from
effete officials earlier today and
something that was mentioned a couple
times was you know in these kind of
competitive environments there are all
these psychological elements some of
them can be taken to account in advance
others cannot and this sort of notion
that if you really wanted to play you
would have been there in fact even
Magnus Carlsen said that he thought you
didn't really want to be there because
the Kansas is a tough event
and maybe you weren't up for it so I
mean what do you make of these claims
both by feet a and the world champion
well it's a personal opinion first of
all I think that the world champion
certainly has his personal opinion as me
for example as a top chess player as
well I have some other opinions when he
when he does something so I have also my
own opinion it's a personal opinion so
its first of all it's not supported by
by by the facts and if we're speaking
with the from the legal point certainly
as well is that I just you know won the
spot to play the candidates and I was
legally there I was preparing for the
candidates wanting to play it and it is
probably can be in any unit of players
life the last candidates tournament
always you never know if you are getting
back into this you know into this
business trying to trying to qualify for
Mario's form agonistic and the match
against Q of course yeah and certainly I
mean first of all let's take it is it a
tournament in this circumstances when
everything is closed
everything is postponed and all the
events in the entire you know other
sport events and stuff is postponed and
also it's officially going to be stopped
I mean by this Ministry of sports and
stuff like that is it the way to conduct
the tournament in this situation first
question is it normal I think not beside
that my willingness to fight for the
world crown and you know to play in the
candidates tournament it's my own
decision I am playing there I am in the
tournament I am preparing for the
tournament and some people can say he
has no chances let's say so doesn't
matter if you played is it considered as
just a normal thing that maybe he just
shouldn't play there
what do you think if another player was
writing that letter they would have
stopped the tournament
I think if Carlson for example would
write that letter the tournament will be
canceled
I mean I guess if Khurana or others
would say that Caruana
I guess would have a huge impact on this
as well I think this is the not the
right sink to be honest you know to to
to happen in general but certainly we
understand that world champion has like
how to say I mean they feel his opinion
much more than all the others
and it's generally understandable
because he's a world champion
so generally of course I mean if he's
not playing the match let's say I mean
they should think about you know
changing the world cycle or stuff like
that or if you you know it happened as
many times they were even different
systems that were found out you know
this different systems where you played
the match for the world crown like
cramming against Kasparov and there is a
fee the world championships of different
you know situation that happened of
course while Chapman has some kind of
huge impact on this certainly if he
would be there and he would say no the
tournament will be postponed
it's hard to judge I mean why he
generally thinks that why he generally
thinks that I was not going to withstand
this pressure stuff like that it's I
mean I was standing the pressure in the
World Cup for one month I guess I will
be okay to withstand the pressure for 20
days but in this circumstance is just
not not right to play the tournament we
have seen the consequences that actually
proves me right so now certainly I mean
it's even I mean it's just I think not
right even to discuss this from my from
my side in the situation to real a lot I
mean to make a lot of comments on both
champions world champions personal
opinion this is his personal opinion I'm
fine with it I mean he can say
everything he wants in general and it's
fine but there is also the situation
that we can see now the tournament is
stopped halfway through with unclear
consequences with total D concentration
and you are playing like seven rounds
now and seven rounds in I don't know one
year or half a year or three months or
whatever it's a different tournament
different players as you say for example
let's say there are eight players who
came to this tournament and they're
super ready and someone is ready better
than the
in this circumstances and now it's
postponed and now we see completely
different players in three monsters
because nobody knows what is the
situation how they handle it was the
situation now you know in their
countries if they're able to fly it back
okay they're able let's say to fight
back hopefully and stuff like that is a
different concentration completely so
they can come again for the new
tournament which is not started as a new
probably because they have already some
kind of points so I mean good sync can
be only for the players that are you
know there because they can maybe
perform better if it starts in three
monsters or stuff like that so it's
really a kind of personal opinions hard
to comment on it to be honest I mean
what I said is probably probably also a
personal opinion certainly but I think
in this case it's more correct to ask me
and asked me for my ambitions or my
willingness to play or stuff like that
because it's only me who knows the real
situation I mean you know in particular
would in my case because I'm certainly
was able to fight and was able to
prepare there were no problems for me
and so I was going I prepared everything
actually my team was ready to go there I
had no problems at all was it we
appreciate you cheering uh no honestly
and openly your feelings and thoughts
about this I think regardless of the
opinion of one person whether the world
champion or not I think I can say my
opinion I remember as you were I think
when we first met in Moscow 2002 you
were the new boy from Baku following Inc
as far as footsteps and I I've seen for
many years your ambition and desire to
become the world champion so I agree
with you and I and I don't believe it's
a fair or just this storyline at all I
know we know you wanted to be there and
I appreciate you being so honest and
open with your feelings about that I
have a couple more questions if you're
willing sorry you just won think you had
about Carlson's opinion in this case is
that generally we don't know what would
happen if he would be there first of all
and I can tell you that if you would see
the situation with the virus I'm not
sure that he would push this participate
especially that he has a team of the
managers and so on that would probably
say that in these circumstances you
don't play there we do not suggest you
to play in the circumstances and you
should talk to Fay there or
write a letter I guess it would be I
mean in my if I can also express my
personal opinion I think that would be
the case with his team in this situation
on a match not even sure that they would
start the match like this for example
the match one-on-one even if they say
that eight players were there with two
thousand spectators on the opening
ceremony but beside that I mean if you
would say that there is a match now or
something not sure even his management
would support a decision to play the
match in the circumstances even though
that there are only two players playing
and so on so generally I think that you
know in this in this case I'm not sure
that he would play in the circumstances
because now he's actually commenting
from home and so on he's more relaxed
and certainly when the pressure is there
and when you really have to play a
tournament for three weeks and you know
that anything can really affect it and
especially imagine you are now going on
the first place and it's getting cancer
like this like we can see now when you
are preparing for your next game and
then they tell you you have to pack and
certainly go fast home and so on and
like really run out of the country for
now is it is it just something normal
when when as I said when everything else
is canceled when the situation close to
the door and a few days before the
tournament was clear that you have to
postpone I don't understand this
decision but about Carlson's opinion my
personal appeal about Carlsen is that
generally I think him and his team maybe
not him probably but his team in this
case they would consider seriously if he
has to plan it
and yeah the the lots are totally
appreciated III wanted to know given the
given just one last thing I'm sorry no
no he said of course don't forget it I
have a very good relations with Carlsen
his family and actually his team as well
I mean it's no it's just the personal
opinions from him and from me so it's we
don't have any problems so it's right so
and it's good it's good to know and I
think it was just kind of giving the
community letting us give you the
opportunity to make sure people know how
much this matters to you and that's the
reason I shared the story I did of
remembering you know for a very long
time watching your chest career and I
just want to say speaking of watching
chess have you been following the event
and if so how closely given the
frustrated perspective you would have
about this have you been watching the
candidates over this week or have you
not been engaged that much no of course
I'm following the event certainly I mean
I mean the actually to be in two words
chess is my life yeah I mean it's like
always when there's something important
I'm following it I mean when there are
some important games or sometimes even
the Bliss games or stuff like that even
having fun and so on you know watching
games like police games or rapid events
and stuff like that but especially of
course when there are some top players
playing against each other
of course I'm following it and
especially the candidates for now but at
the same time I know that Napoleon she's
sick I don't know if badly but he's sick
there he's feeling not good at all and
I've probably had had no impact maybe
had some impact on his game against
Russia de Graaff you played a very good
game yesterday in general and certainly
yeah of course I'm falling but generally
I mean I don't think that the level
really su as good as it should be or
this tournament and some some of the top
players that were considered at the
favor it's marijuana and dink I have my
general how to say concerns about the
Jing clearance spending two weeks
you know somewhere outside Moscow there
and which which really impacts his play
a lot is what I think because I mean
income parents in you know in not at
your home not in your hometown and
really before such an important event I
think it's a it's a hard thing to do to
bear which is also I think bells in his
games in general I think you you
wouldn't even expect him to play like
this in who first rounds certainly could
happen in any other tournament I'm not
saying but but I mean this really has
some impact I guess and caranas play at
the at the moment is far from far from
brilliant
well I I have what one follow-up that I
wanted to get your opinion of and and I
think a lot of people watching this
obviously the broadcast online are
curious if if feed a hadn't had made a
decision and decided to run the 20 20
feet a candidates as an online event i
under circumstances assuming everyone
would be proctored closely within within
maybe by a feed a arbiter in a better
more sort of controllable setting
obviously for Kovan 19 concerns right
but assuming those circumstances were
handled properly and that the spread of
the virus was not a concern
would you have considered playing the
event while it is sort of unprecedented
I think there are some some interesting
things to consider the NBA while it is
NBA 2k on twitch right now is still not
the NBA it's not LeBron playing against
Yanis right there there's arguments for
chess that chess is the same game online
as it is over the board right would you
have considered an online replacement
for the 2020 fidei candidates
appropriate and would you have
participated if Vijay had chosen to go
that route Fischer if I'm not mistaken
was playing at some point by the
telephone was it was there was some
national yes and by Morse code long back
in the day but go ahead yeah but to be
honest I think it's like it's closer to
me to the today you know I mean of
course there online chess is a great
thing you know and all these blitzes and
rapid sometimes just keeps you in shape
and so on for for many other events and
so on
but I think it would be a bit closer to
the tennis match that you would put
Federer in Switzerland and Nadal in
Spain they would play against each other
would be the same I think it's really
different I think in chess it's a lot
different when you play online when you
play the real blitz I mean for example
but beside that for this event I mean it
would be like only you in the room like
just moving the business and someone in
front of you moving for your open it you
don't feel you don't feel the you know
the the the you know the face you don't
see the face of your opening properly I
guess and then you don't feel how how he
feels about the position
what emotions and so stuff like I mean
it would be hard I would consider it but
it would be really hard to do I mean
different person I made that it is at
least the same X's and O's online as it
is over the board right as far as the
TPM itself right that's a datastore you
know go ahead I was just curious I mean
it's a different it's different it's the
same game but different story completely
different kind of event I mean you
should feel all the others you should
see the are there is other participants
their feelings all this stuff how they
behave how they feel all that stuff I
mean really matters a lot during your
games sometimes can one one real you
know smile over the board of your open
it or something can change a lot and you
know there are all this you know cases
that somebody's even speaking during the
games and all that stuff and somebody's
you know doing something during the game
with you with the phone or the piece or
stuff all this stuff is like it's a game
of two people against each other playing
one in front of the other and I don't
think that's really this online online
sync and in this case help such a such a
great event especially that I think it
will be a different story simply I mean
it's cool to make like maybe non
official candidates throw them in there
and see those and try something or make
an event of I don't know like seven
rounds with with some nice prize money
or stuff to see how it goes but
generally I think it's a different story
maybe you can do something with cameras
when you see your opponents and all
these rooms like you know like VR
whatever you may be there are some
things like this but in general I think
at the moment I don't think it would be
a proper way to conduct this tournament
well appreciate the thoughts I think
it's interesting to see what a top-level
player feels so much about seeing the
emotional the body language of their
opponents I think it's it's insight for
fans either way to hear your perspective
on what that competitive environment is
like watching watching someone flick the
pawn in their hand right and just all
that stink it's I think it's fascinating
either way actually I somehow in in some
in some you know in some situation let's
say in the World Cup my my for example
body language was not the best but
somehow this way I managed to trick them
all because I was a super shape
generally for calculation
and like you know the opening wise I was
preparing on my own but I was really
doing a lot of work there
even during they went and so in this
case you know what my body language was
so bad that they saw that they're
probably playing against someone that
will collapse now but actually that was
the vice versa situation well tomorrow
as we wrap this up thank you so much for
our time I do have a question for you if
field officials are watching this is
there anything you would like to say
from them say to them excuse me and you
know do you want an apology from them at
this point certainly but not I mean
first of all to the chest community of
course because I think it's a it's a
shame what is happening now and I can
see also a lot of fans I mean really
thousands of people writing about the
situation and don't Twitter and so on
and mostly of course I see it when they
mention you know my name on Twitter and
then I seal or comments of course but in
general I think they should apologize to
the entire Jewish community it cannot be
supported in my understanding non
legally known by the just common sense
what what has happened for now and it's
an unprecedented situation that was my
mind it was easy to avoid it it was much
easier to avoid it than to really now
fight with this consequences I mean it's
just I mean their idea for now is in
general to just conduct the tournament
and finish the tournament so now it's
all they want to do and in this
situation I am in general I mean I have
a contact and certainly I was talking
actually you asked it I didn't answer
and with the Phaedo representatives was
Arkady to our coach we were expressing
the messages and so on about about the
situation and I was actually telling him
that is going to be really bad but okay
so for now we have what we have and it's
a pity that certainly at some point I
think it there is a problem that I have
also expressed in one of the posts on
Instagram is that it's an individual
sport mostly and so there is no like the
disassociation of chess profession
should be more active in this case but
they send letters to feed it that was
not answered as far as I understood and
beside that I think there should be more
like voices raised or whatever in such
situations like for example if I wanted
to decline the door demand should really
speak out and say that he supports my
decision or something or he's going to
be out of the tournament or Caruana
for example Khurana wrote that you want
to be he said that he has no other
options for now rather than to play in
the tournament as he is there already
and so on but I think in general that if
players as you ask me for example if
Carlson would say imagine Carlson says
I'm not playing in this tournament in
the first round or before the first
round then I have doubts that Fida would
come back the tournament just stop it if
you would say that I have concerns so in
this case I think Caruana one cow maybe
other players technically shoot they had
to somehow they are already at being at
the tournament maybe before the start
when they saw this minister of sports
from you know the band and stuff like
that maybe they had to speak out but
certainly this is a bit of a problem for
chess because it's an individual sport
so everybody speaks on it's on his own
and there is not much of the court you
know between the players and so on so
generally that's why we have this
situation where we're only generally
what for example what world champion
will say will matter in general that's
why we don't have this kind of saying
that okay let's say Roger declines guys
the situation is really terrible we
don't know what will happen and so on
let's postpone it let's live an open
letter to feed there let's do some
things and so on so it would be much
easier if somebody else like Khurana or
other players would say that they agree
with my decision and they think that it
should be postponed and let's write
let's do something together so that
would be that would be the case I think
the right thing to do from our side but
of course it doesn't it doesn't take out
the responsibility from feeded was there
a governing body and they should be
first to
anymore I can't say enough how much we
appreciate you you being here and giving
your thoughts it's just obviously trying
times
disappointing times but also the the
opportunity to get insight and and and
this type of expression from a player of
your class is also unique and
appreciated for everyone despite the
despite that unique times here so I
think thank you so much thank you so
much have a great afternoon there's
Michigan State stay safe stay stay sane
stay happy stay healthy thank you very
much thank you so much thanks tomorrow
thank you I hope to see you again there
there we have it that was tame over Java